[Musique]
bonjour yves-marie grivalliers bonjour
mot visuel tombeau jose auditrices et
auditeurs de martinique la première êtes
le coordinateur de l'os pm
l'observatoire sociopolitique de
l'église en martinique l'église
catholique qui a sa façon s'est penché
sur les 170 ans de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé près d'une demi douzaine de
conférences l'an dernier les conclusions
de toutes ces conférences seront
restitués ce soir à bellevue l'os pen
veut parler de droit de suite après ce
cycle de conférences
oui alors avant de répondre à votre
question monsieur viol ton je voudrais
donc citer une quelque chose que une
phrase qui dit que le le respect de
l'homme vous l'homme en fait ce qui
s'est passé il ya un an donc dans votre
émission
j'avais dit en conclusion guise de
conclusion une interview que j'avais
dans cette émission que nous aurions
donc concrétiser notre que les
conférences par une brochure
donc voilà donc si je vous dis que le
respect de l'homme voulons donc nous
avons tenu à faire en sorte que ce
document saute et pourquoi de la move le
qu'ils sont en fait tout simplement et
cela permettra de répondre à votre
question également c'est parce que nous
nous sommes dit que nous avions des
intervenants de qualité avec des sujets
vraiment et pas autant que comme
l'esclavagé la souffrance et ça nous
permettra également donc nous parle de
rétablir certaines vérités par rapport à
ce qui a été dit sur l'église à ce
moment-là et également permettre aux
jeunes donc le pouvoir bénéficier d'un
support qui permettrait de god tout
connaître des éléments sur l'histoire de
l'église et du pays en martinique
parce que lorsque vous avez initié ce
cycle de conférences l'église catholique
en martinique en a pris plein la tronche
il ya eu des moqueries des railleries
des accusations vous a été montré du
doigt pointé du doigt oui mais vous
savez dans la vie
nous avons quand vous avez d'une
institution qui existe et qu'elle que
son institution d'ailleurs
d'institutions vous avez des personnes
qui sont les actions qui sont positives
d'autres négatives et le plus souvent et
dans la société ce qu'on retient c'est
le négatif nous au cours de ses
conférences nous avons voulu montrer que
tout ce qu'on a pu dire sur l'église qui
étaient favorables esclavage et tout
cela c'est faux que comme je vous dis
dans les institutions
elle commençait dans une institution
soit vous avez 3 363 choix soit vous
restez là dedans et vous accusez vous
restez là dedans vous ne faites rien
soit vous résistez
et vous aussi c'est de faire changer les
choses ou à ce moment-là vous partie il
y à niveau de l'église des courants anti
esclavagiste qui se sont battus pour que
les choses puissent évoluer au niveau de
l' esclavage
je peux partir si vous voulez de la
partie centrale ya des exemples épisode
est vif et bi fans de noir
locke & key qui était donc un capucin
est qui et qui a quand même combattu
c'est l'attitude de ces esclavagistes en
guyane il ya anne marie javouhey en
martinique nous avons eu la bi goua en
guadeloupe la baie du goujon tout ça
vous dit qu'il ya des courants qui ont
été mis de côté et que personne nous
avons voulu nous sommes tant la
réconcilier nos gueules les lys l'église
avec son histoire
certes il ya des choses mauvaises qu'un
défaite mais avec des choses de qualité
des choses nouvelles ya quand même eu ce
feu vert donné pour la traite négrière
qui c'est qui était quantifier au bas
mot chiffres les plus bas autour de 20
millions de personnes déportées mais
monsieur lé génocide des peuples
autochtones qui ont été rayés de la
carte monsieur viol dont je me donne un
exemple je vous invite même aux
auditeurs à lire la brochure
ils sont sympas que vous allez voir que
il ya un exemple s'est produit à sierra
leone on a donné à ddd des personnes
libérées à des tiers et qu'est ce qu'ils
ont fait ils ont établi esclavage est le
propre frère ne voyez dans la vie il ya
des choses qui peuvent se faire d'autres
nous vous savez moi je nous sommes
actuellement en 2019 et ce que nous
voulons c'est aller de l'avant c est ne
pas ne pas nier ce qui s'est passé mais
aller de l'avant et fait des
propositions
alors juste vous rappeler quelque chose
à bord le 250e anniversaire de
l'abolition d'exclure les pulsions
sauvages
les évêques de martinique de guadeloupe
de la ligne de la guyane ont produit un
document qui s'appelait esclavage
absolue abce abolition et libération
nous sommes tous humains nous pour mieux
façonner l'avenir en 1930 pour le 70e
anniversaire
nous avons voulu faire cette
réconciliation est peut-être pour le
190ème peut-être qu'ils ont autre chose
en tête que je suis là pour ce soir
la question est ce que tout cela est
suffisant au moment où il ya quand même
de plus en plus de voix qui parle de
réparation de justice
l'écriture plus juste de l'histoire
alors est ce que je vais vous narrer
ordinale etc donne pendant nos
conférences nous avons eu l'occasion
d'avoir monsieur marseille est venu deux
fois mais malheureusement pour lui
veulent à chaque fois elle a fait des
conférences je sais pas pourquoi vous
voulez pas récent et tire mais pour vous
dire que soap tellement ouvert nous
invitons tout le monde donne confiance
et nous échangeons avec eux parce que
chacun effectivement à son sa façon de
voir le mihrab est une façon de voir la
réparation
le cran autre chose mais nous au niveau
de l'église cadre de l'église nous
demandons c'est trois choses d'abord la
réparation 7 mai la réconciliation et le
pardon
si nous avons passé trois là ne pourront
pas aller de l'avant il va encore
toujours db ceux qui sont là et
malheureusement nous ne pourrons pas les
deux lames et au moment d'organiser ces
conférences était facile de faire face à
tout cela parce que l'argumentation si
facilement avancer de dire qu' il y à la
fois il y a les agissements de certaines
personnes au sein de l'institution
c'est facile de faire face à ça alors
que d'autres scandales sont son be2
vraie actualité comme le scandale de la
pédophilie ou bien des scandales de
moeurs qui 4 jeux partout
vous avez chacun au sein de l'église
d'admission ma mission c'était celle-là
au niveau de la halle au sperme ces
données établies notamment passé le
parti n'a pas sur le stand s'occupe pas
uniquement de l'esclave de l'activité
sur les personnes âgées sur l'exode des
jeunes mais c'est notre mission la
poussée ce cycle de conférences était de
faire en sorte que nous puissions
rétablissait de vite et je vous je vous
affirme je vous assure que l'année
dernière il ya beaucoup de votre
compréhension eu lieu mais le yoga sous
l'église a changé par rapport à ce que
nous avons fait et ça continue à le
faire parce que nous avons cette mission
de rétablir la vérité ne pas nier ce qui
s'est passé et aller de l'avant et fait
des propositions c'est ça la vérité ou
plutôt de se prendre un courant oui mais
en fait vous allez voir que dans je vous
ai dit dans dix ans peut-être qu'on
verra par un peu de propagande ya peu de
communication et non en mode séduction
également nonce pas lieu d'être
il yad'autres que d'autres circuits
religieux qui existent notamment qui
viennent d'amérique du nord
non mais nous sommes en face à cela nous
sommes non nous sommes dans notre
mission qui est de continuer a fait en
sorte de faire prendre conscience à la
population martiniquaise et les coachs
et notamment et j'ai à vous dire que de
nos conférences quand même le sperme qui
est qui qui est là qui existait à peine
deux ans trois ans
ça nous arrive a invité dans une
confiance le professeur chan nicolas
quand même que le connaissez vous avez
quand même des personnes qui est qui qui
sont venus dans nos réunions et qui ont
fait en sorte que faire avancer le débat
et ce que nous prônons et c'est la seule
ouverture l'ouverture c'est d'être
permet de discuter avec les autres et
d'échangés de fait en sorte que les
choses évoluent notre société très bien
avec ce cahier de l'ocpm qui sera qui
sera présenté ce soir à la salle
paroissiale de bellevue vous espérez
quoi de quelles seront les suites de
cette contribution c'est à dire ce
fascicule d'une centaine de pages
qu'est-ce que vous alors est-ce que vous
en attendez alors dans un premier temps
que je vous dis donc déjà vrai
distribuer ce document demandé aux
invités qui seront là mais également
donc que dans tous les mouvements
d'église mais également à l'extérieur ce
à dire que comme je vous dis essaie de
faire un travail avec l'éducation
nationale
de fait en sorte que ce document soit
travaillé avec pour des jeunes avec des
professeurs d'histoire parce que quand
même cette boucherie est égalisé avec le
professeur d'histoire géographie
c'est tout ce que nous ne ferons pas
sous les dettes et faire en sorte que ce
document là pu servir donc demain matin
de ce combat lambin mois on pourra dire
au moins un organisme qui existe dans
l'église qui a voulu faire en sorte qu'
il ya des traces de la vérité pour sur
l'église en martinique veut faire
davantage peuple avec avec tout ce qui
toutes les composantes de la société les
politiques par exemple vous aviez déjà
organisé une sorte de forum face aux
politiques qui se présentait à
l'élection de la ctm ya eu cette prise
de position de l'église dans le cadre du
débat l'article 73 74 il n'avait plus
impliquer davantage dans la vie de ce
pays oui tout à fait et je vous dis que
nous avons fait des 10/10 vendredi
dernier une conférence sur les élections
européennes
nous avons invité des politiques nous
avons gagné ce soir de notre réunion a
un lien politique qui va répondre et
nous avons également en projet de faire
un pèlerinage avec des hommes politiques
donc au mois d'octobre pour vous dire
que nous sommes ouverts à tout le monde
politique syndicaliste aussi un tout le
monde est prêt à une seconde et dernière
position concernant l'exode des jeunes
la santé le siège au délabrement le
chlordécone et sorgues à tout pilote
même le respect des droits lgbt lesbien
gay mini-train nous sommes alors nous
sommes alors nous sommes ouverts à tous
seront des atouts mais notre priorité je
vous dis donc c'est le travail de
l'exode des jeunes
effectivement le vieillissement de la
population et
on fait en sorte que nous puissions
faire progresser la discussion en entier
merci yves marie xvi aura plus que
coordinateur de l'observatoire
sociopolitique de l'église à martigues
bonne journée merci